there's a secret extra tax you pay every
year and it's not just to the government
your health insur your phone company
even your employer takes a cut of your
time it's been called the time tax or
administrative burden and it refers to
how ordinary people are being asked to
spend more and more of their lives
filling out forms sitting on hold and
waiting in line it's a way for companies
and agencies to save money on labor but
it's also to discourage people from
accessing benefits and payments they're
entitled to a struggling parent might
not get food stamps because they can't
get time off for an in-person interview
a sick patient might not have the energy
to battle their HMO to pay their medical
bills even canceling an online
subscription can be just enough of a
hassle to make some people keep paying
of course we have to expect that living
in the modern world will involve some
paperwork but if time is money we have a
right to know how much we're paying
there's a secret extra tax you pay every
year and it's not just to the government
your health insur your